salut ça vous arrive souvent de flipper
d'avoir une angoisse et bien aujourd'hui
j'ai invité un grand médecin un grand où
vivent non pas du tout j'invite à un
comédien pour nous parler de traque et
c'est rudy milstein salut salut salut
salut salut vous allez bien j'ai
l'impression qu'on va passer un moment
c'est le goal add on va vous parler du
trac aujourd'hui c'est parti générique
au long de l'année régulièrement dans
les commentaires vous m'avez demandé si
j'avais des trucs des astuces pour gérer
le trac et de trac c'est quelque chose
qu'on vit souvent on le vit en milieu
professionnel personnel
il n'y a pas que sur la scène mais quand
même comme rudy c'est un excellent
comédien dans les malheurs de riz dit je
t'ai vu dans copains comme cochons
j'étais plus un attaquant j'ai pris la
bonne situation
je vis dans plein d'autres choses
j'étais obligé de tuer tant de grands
théâtres il n'a pas tout assumer
mais taper redit sur youporn évolue à
londres mais je te laisse je fais chier
tout à leur aise quand même là tu vois
redire en train de vivre vraiment du
trac
alors est ce que toi avant de monter sur
scène on devrait juste pour porto por te
présenter un peu mieux des comédiens tu
fais pas mal de choses sur scène tu fais
pas mal de choses avec l'atelier palmade
ouais tu as tourné dans un long métrage
un peu moins droit de 3 c'est vrai ouais
mais peut-être qu'on se connaissait pas
pour les deux autres 6 alors il ya eu le
film de clovis cornillac un peu beaucoup
aveuglément mais j'ai été coupé au
montage est en fait si tu voyais film tu
vois juste rigaud n'est pas citer tous
les fils au game excision est vu comme
ça et après je veux donc une julie delpy
n'aurait pas été coupée et là j'ai joué
dans un film qui est pas encore sorti
que deux cent cinquante ans ab non mais
c'est pour ça
embrasse moi de faire cette veine mais
non mais moi du coup que je le dis je
joue en deux
je hais ce que tu as du trac avant de
monter sur scène avant un tournage avant
un interview avant quelque chose est ce
que c'est une émotion qui connaît bah
ouais tout le temps même dans la vie
tout le temps et ça se traduit comment
chez toi je sens et quand le c'est là
tout devient ici là tout se met d'accord
c'est plus du tout le corps qui parle
ouais et du coup c'est tout le mental
qui vient tout contrôler donc en fait tu
te sens dissociation un peu ouais ça
quand je sors du corps et je sens que
d'un coup je suis là et puis tout à coup
je serai là je fais quel poste je prends
message aimerais tu t'es pas dû croire
jusqu'au bout suivant
donc du coup quelle date les annonces à
sanaa mais il a mis ce bras ajouté
l'alliance annonce apprise c'est plutôt
corte à des degrés différents de trac
qui va de deux je me contrôle à
l'angoissé totale donc il ya un lien il
ya des efforts ma part tout moment où je
peux contrôler c'est qu'il ya un manque
de confiance
wa quels sont tes solutions dans ces
gars là pour faire baisser ces émotions
d'angoise est ce que tu as des rituels
est ce que tu as des toiles dit nous
tous les gens veulent savoir les abonnés
cherche à savoir et on est en train de
taper le nom des films sur internet
sortante papilloud par louis ii le 2
la respiration ouais j'inspire pardonner
et je visualise tellement passionnant
jusqu'à en fait j'ai une déformation de
cloison nasale
ah oui je me suis fait opérer les élèves
de classes dernière il ya deux ans j'ai
récupéré la respiration par l'année
quand j'arrivais part espéré pardonner
donc comme pearl sonné par le ventre
aussi
ouais c'est ça ouais de visualiser le
souffle qui passe et d'un coup ça me
permet de me remettre
c'est des trucs de méditation pas
étonnant que ouais on avait parlé de
choses comme ça qu'on avait parlé de se
relaxer qu'on avait parlé de focaliser
sur sa concentration
en fait ça c'est un bon truc qui marche
qui est facile à faire donc commencé à
être un peu angoissé que ça va pas ça
vous prend à la tête ou au ventre il ya
beaucoup qui ressentent le trac par le
ventre
merci je voulais pas le cas alors là il
une explication scientifique 1 c'est que
regarde quand quand un animal a peur et
nous quand on avait peur
le meilleur moyen pour faire fuir
l'adversaire c'est de le dégoûter dans
l'odeur une autre adresse un carton à
2,5 terre qui se relâche
c'est pour ça que si tu te fais agresser
dans la rue avec l'arrivée au couteau tu
peux vraiment littéralement toshiki
dessus mais c'est parce que c'est un
lacet de serveurs et indiens qui prend
les commandes et c'est nos réflexes
animalier cinqueterre qu'ils il a pour
but pisse dessus quand t'as quand tu
veux quand tu as peur enfin soit tu sais
pas moi ce marais sous les gens le
savent
du coup la respiration parce que je sais
exactement de quoi on parle et je prends
des notes dans ma tête
vous pouvez faire cette chose très
simple donc quand ça commence à venir à
la tête ou dans le ventre de respirer
par le nez mais de visualiser vraiment
le souffle qui rentrent de visualiser
arrivée dans les poumons
vous pouvez même visualiser les change
de tout cet oxygène qui rentre et qui se
rechargent après des choses un peu plus
négative le co2 toutes ces choses là et
de visualiser l'expiration par le nez ou
par la bouche mais en plus de ça en se
focalisant dessus déjà on pense à autre
chose
on revient sur l'instant présent et non
pas sur des projections de peur et puis
ça va vous de redonner un rythme
cardiaque enfants en réalité ça va vous
ré oxygéner ça c'est très facile à faire
ouais et lui-même tu parles de théâtre
ou de tournage et tout ça mais même dans
l'avion j'ai quand jal avant j'avais pas
du tout peur de l'avion est en fait je
vous fur et à mesure je flippais
vraiment beaucoup en avion et un jour je
lisais de pouvoir du moment présent dans
l'avion de
2 juste ici des cartes ré carto les
cartons des voix voici le pouvoir de
l'instant présent je vous mettrai dans
la description s'il y en a qui veulent
et donc j'étais dans l'avion et puis il
y avait il parlé d'un coup de sa du
moment voilà de juste de respirer de
revenir dans son corps et tout et je
faisais ça et d'un goût en fait j'étais
aux habitants un peu ce que vous
attendez comprendre d'intégrer tout ça
est en fait d'un coup j'étais hyper bien
dans cet avion
j'avais plus du tout pareil j'essayais
mettre moi c'est ça et du coup j'étais
là et en fait j'étais pas dans les
projections de on va s'écraser
c'est marrant parce que tu vois je je
pensais pas qu'on allait aborder ça dans
la vidéo met effectivement en fait en
faisant ça tu traites complètement le la
cause de du trac et non pas les
symptômes et la cause du trac c'est
toujours des espèces de projection de
peur de ce qui peut mal se passer
donc si tu coupes ça en train menant
tout de suite dans la réalité non pas
dans ce que pourra être le futur mais il
ya même plus le trac
ouais symptômes et puis de se mettre
dans son corps ou si ça va vite 2d dans
des projections de ce que pensent et
autres est-ce que tu devais souvent dans
le corps des autres comme ça on va voir
on se lâche pour rudy milstein aulas me
saluent la dame me stein la vraie c'est
sur borne up non pas dans le corps des
eaux dans la tête de l'oif dû coûter
dans une projection de ce qu'ils vont
penser à toi aller sur scène s'ouvre ya
ça tu t'es au bout de la 150e quand tu
connais exactement des réactions du
public jeudi six idées parfois si t'es
pas bien dans le moment tu t'amuses pas
vraiment été juste dans la merde et au
moins ils ont mal réagi que d'habitude
ils ont moins rigoler que d'habitude et
en fait c'est pas bon du tout comme ça
parce que du coup tu es dans un truc de
hockey c'est un projet tout ce qu'ils
pensent alors que cit juste et dans tu
fais se trouver l'inspiration c'est dans
ton corps tu t'en fous tu pas dans les
projections mentales s'en fout en fait
c'est un régal moi tu t'en fous tu es
juste je fais ton truc tu t'amuses tête
dedans
vous savez quoi je vais synthétiser de
zoua seuils de rudy je parle mal le
premier nom c'est qu'on parle trop c'est
trop
le premier c'est de faire un petit
exercice de respiration aussi simple que
celui qu'on dont on vient de parler et
le deuxième c'est de ne pas faire
d'hypothèses
en fait je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez j'avais fait une vidéo sur les
accords toltèques lupu la trouvez vous
tapez fabien olicard accords toltèques
et de désaccord le texte sont ne pas
faire d'hypothèses et ne pas en faire
une affaire personnelle est vraiment
fait c'est si tu mixes les trois après
ça va ça va mieux est-ce que tu connais
des personnes qui ont d'autres rituels
comme ça qui sera intéressant ou
amusants à dire je me regarde pas les
autres m'ont foutu il très égoïste
lanouf est au centre est en fait et j'en
ai rien à branler les autres maisons
mères puissent tous des comédiens qui
jouaient avec qui il joue you'll see
your way c'est toujours ce truc-là de
respiration de concentration après ça se
manifeste de manière différente que
chacun s'il y en a qui sont ils se
mettent à l'aise en faisant des blagues
tu vas en se mettant dans un truc
détendu donc en amenant des tentes et
amène à des tentes en la forçant un peu
tout ça c'est hyper intéressant comme
discussions on sent bien qu'on pourrait
en parler très longtemps néanmoins ça va
être beaucoup trop long pour vous déjà
je pense que cette vidéo va passer les
10 minutes et vous remarquerez qu'il
n'ya pas de coupure publicitaire dans ma
vidéo qui dépasse les 10 minutes c'est
pas pour ça merci beaucoup a dit d'être
venu ce soir à la maison parce qu'on est
hier soir au moment où vous voyez cette
vidéo oui merci c'est cool eh ben non
merci à toi il serait bien d'avoir
quelqu'un qui est souvent sur les
planchers qu'est le stress aussi de
tourner dans des longs métrages et tout
parce que c'est
on pense souvent à ça au trac mais comme
tu l'as si bien rappelé c'est aussi dans
le quotidien
même des fois le fait d'aller parler à
quelqu'un qui nous plaît aux choses
comme ça alors vous pouvez faire ses
exercices de respiration et ne pas
émettre d'hypothèses de parler comme tu
dis dans le cerveau de l'autre pour
essayer de penser à sa place pensez à
vous fait le truc qui fait le moment et
ça va vous aider à diluer le stress est
ce que c'était pas mortel mais ces
villages
est ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on s'enlève a
parlé avant des trucs de méthode mais
qu'en fait on était raccord oui c'est
vrai oui carrément
alors au rugby ou est-ce qu'on peut te
voir dans une pièce comme cousin au
cochon comme tu veux pas dire le public
c'est vrai pas rudi wulf stein où est-ce
qu'on peut venir te voir sur scène un
tueur au splendid dans cousin comme
cochons tu vas bien dit qu'ils se
trompent orange avait dit relative en
fait un mélange de votre ville
ouais être comédie musicale ouais c'est
ça et en fait ce que je savais pas c'est
qu'avant les vaudevilles c'était
toujours musicale assez drôle je devrais
de vous être revenir un peu à la source
et doit sortir le sait nicolas brenas
auteur metteur en scène et compositeur
qui a élu nuit dans le film parodie il a
fait une parodie de boudeville elle rôle
c'est complètement débile et nicolas
mayer qui qui qui faisait partie des
quatre personnes qui s'occupaient de la
colonie des trois-bornes dzeko
exactement à la molina si tu sais moi je
vois un mec je vous mettre le lien dans
la description et puis et puis voilà
c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire
ben j'ai l'air n'ya pas de chaîne
youtube n'ont donc abonnez-vous à la
mienne à la place évidemment j'imagine
que vous aussi vous avez vos petites
techniques pour gérer le stress et les
angoisses de métal et dans les
commentaires on verra un petit peu ce
qui s'en dégage s'il y en a qui ont
débuté des méthodes particulières ou
qu'on n'a rien à voir dans découvrir des
nouvelles peut être fait des super
technique
ah bah ouais faut peut-être ils ont des
trucs complètement what the fuck you
peut être très drôle à dire si bien
rendez vous demain à 17 heures puisque
le mental box est toujours une vidéo par
jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
ciao ciao ciao
[Musique]